good morning John it's a very busy week
here I was out a ton of bunch and now
we're having our senior staff Summit for
complex which means I have very little
time to make a video so this is what you
get and that's fine right when I first
got sick people sent me a bunch of hats
because I was losing my hair and I was
like it's summer but now I still have
them I oh see that's cold getting
together with people at complexly which
is the company that makes sich and Crush
course and eons and bizarre beasts and
microcosmos and study hall and lots of
different shows is always really
wonderful to give like a presentation
and I started it out by saying that I
kind of feel like ultimately there's
like two kinds of content getting made
on the internet there's like haters and
there's fans and making hater content
works well and is easy like you it's
pretty easy to make people mad about
stuff think stuff that gives people
positive emotions and is accurate is
more work and takes more time but you
build a much stronger and more stable
Foundation during our meeting somebody
brought up the fact that the BBC had
recently done a piece on just fake
content being made on YouTube largely
with the help of AI and that content
gets watched by a lot of young people
including like pre-teens and they end up
believing it a lot of it's about aliens
or climate change not being real Etc but
in the video they started out by
watching a bunch of videos that they
said were good and credible and all of
those videos were saow videos trouble is
if you start out with our content you
still end up getting these other videos
recommended to you because they have
very exciting and interesting titles
about how aliens are real in a world of
stuff that I'm not like super happy
exists there's a lot of stuff I don't
love I think a lot about Taylor Swift
and how it is true that it is easy and
fast to make content that outrages
people uh and makes them like sort of
like their world and each other less but
just because it's harder doesn't mean
it's not actually better to do the other
thing where you make things that people
love and you create strong foundations
and build upon them until you take over
the whole damn world which is what
Taylor has done I don't know why she did
it she had a lot of opportunities to say
this is enough and I'm done but she kept
on pushing that's amazing to me because
I'm sure that there were lots of moments
where she dealt with some stuff that was
uh not fun to deal with I know I make
educational media and that's different
from pop songs but I feel like
everybody's got a lot to learn from
Taylor Swift and the big puse is even
though it's harder it's a better way to
do stuff to make things that will give
people positive emotions rather than
negative emotions and that's different
from only ever talking about happy stuff
like not every Taylor Swift song is
Happy you could talk about how mess up
the world is but not be sort of driving
people toward hopelessness cuz that's
the easiest way to control them I'm
almost to my destination so the last
thing I will say is that right now uh
you probably need a calendar cuz it's
about to be a new year and we got a
bunch of those at complexing
calendars.com we got one for eons and
for bizarre beasts and for
microcosmos and for SI show and I I
think that's it but you can go to
complexity calendars.com and pick the
ones that you want that helps support
what we're doing at complexly and it
also will be like a nice little thing
with some beautiful art and some cool
information that is accurate and fact
checked and vetted thanks to everybody
working to make complexly a thing and
make it work and make it good I'm so
proud of it so happy be a part of it
John I'll see you on Tuesday I would
prefer the wind to stop also we were
having our at the Arts Community Center
and I saw a fabric scrap and I was like
I recognize that PE it was uh from the
company that manufactures our shirts
they sometimes like obviously will just
do test runs to make sure it works and
they do several of them on the same
shirt and I just spotted a pizza John
shirt was actually a dual Pizza John
shirt with three wolf Moon and pizza
John on it weird just weird I can spot a
pizza John from a mile away you should
definitely have done this with gloves on
you
guys bye